let's let's move on from this let's talk
about abortion sure because uh we have
this story in the news
well we had the story uh we'll we'll
talk about starbucks and then we'll go
into my my tweet so we can talk about uh
the meat potatoes here starbucks will
cover travel expenses for employees
abortion and gender change treatments
starbucks has announced that they will
be covering eligible travel costs for
employees and their family members to
get abortions or gender change
treatments if the services are not
available within 100 miles of where they
live
quote
in 2018 starbucks broadened its health
insurance options for transgender
partners to not only include gender
assignment surgery
which had been covered since 2013 but
also a host of procedures that were
previously considered cosmetic such as
breast reduction and augmentation
surgery facial feminization hair
transplants and more the company said in
a press release so this is
tesla did the same thing actually tesla
announced that if their employees need
an abortion they'll cover the costs i
think amazon did this as well
but let's talk about
this is the news story to kick off what
i actually want to get into so forgive
me for the ridiculous segue but uh i
have a tweet here sure i said what
happens if a woman is on the way to get
an abortion at eight months but goes
into labor in the lobby of the abortion
clinic and accidentally delivers the
baby before it could be terminated so
let me explain the backstory so why i
tweeted this i was having dinner with a
friend in new york
and they said that they were pro-choice
and i said uh do you agree with
abortion
after viability viability of course is
defined as the point at which the baby
can survive on its own
he said uh well no of course not right
but like in the in the first trimester
in the first several weeks like
it's the mother's decision the
government doesn't have a right and i
said okay okay but you say pro-choice
right
so do you think that if like would you
would you favor the democrats position
and he assumed yes i would i think the
republicans want to ban it and all that
stuff and i was like yeah they do but
the democrats tried passing a bill that
would legal that would legalize in many
states
termination of the baby at up to nine
months up to uh the point of birth in
colorado they've already legalized it
kathy tran in virginia tried uh tried
passing a bill uh ralph northam uh
famously talked about it so the bill
proposed by democrats that was recently
voted down does include a provision
h.r 3755 that says
in uh section three paragraph i'm sorry
section four
paragraph nine section four of course
starts by saying a patient has a
corresponding right to receive such
services without any of the following
limitations or requirements section nine
says a prohibition on abortion after
fetal viability when in the good faith
medical judgment of the treating health
care provider continuation of the
pregnancy would pose a risk to the
pregnant patient's life or health i
showed this article to my friend and
said i have a question
if the baby is viable
why kill it
and he said well you wouldn't and i said
what would you do he's like i
i don't know i said okay and he was like
no maybe they're saying just end the
pregnancy and i was like right right but
that's not induced labor is not abortion
is it
maybe maybe
is that what you're saying because if
you're saying induced labor or c-section
is abortion i think we're in agreement
here you can end the pregnancy but
preserve the life of the baby
the definition of abortion according to
merriam-webster though is the
termination of a pregnancy
you know following or directly related
relating to
the death of the baby after the fact
so
i don't understand why they would have
to create a law and try to pass it that
would legalize abortion at all
if a woman is eight months pregnant and
the doctor says if you continue this
pregnancy you will die well then they
deliver the baby
they they they have to remove the baby
right
why kill the baby in the process when
you can just remove it can you can you
read that for me one more time
so
the the important first section uh uh
section of section four uh a general
rule
a healthcare provider has a statutory
right under this act to provide abortion
services and may provide abortion
services and that provider's patient has
a corresponding right to receive such
services
without any of the following limitations
or requirements section 9 reads a
prohibition on abortion after fetal
viability when in the good faith medical
judgment of the treating healthcare
provider continuation of the pregnancy
would pose a risk to the pregnant
patient's life or health
sure okay
in terms and even says uh in the good
faith what was it the good faith good
faith medical decision of the doctor
right if you're carrying a baby up to
eight months i mean you want that baby
if it's if it's a situation where it's
the mother's health um then i mean they
wanted the baby well so if if the
woman's at eight months pregnant why
tweeted this right and well that's a bit
different from what you tweeted a woman
is an eight-month pregnant eight month
so i'm saying the reason i tweeted that
is because if a woman is at eight months
pregnant and she decides to terminate
the pregnancy aborting the baby you
don't you know at eight months pregnant
you don't decide to terminate you have
to terminate because of medical reasons
something's going on so it's not there's
some decision what are you talking about
is it a woman's decision to terminate
the pregnancy or not i mean if the for
her own health i mean it's between her
and her doctor right but are you saying
it's not her decision what do you
i said if a woman decides to terminate a
pregnancy
it's not like she's up and decided to go
i didn't say she up and decided i'm
saying if a woman decides because of
medical issues yeah okay i mean but i
think you have to add because of medical
reasons no no because it's important to
be very specific that people are not
carrying a carrying of you know a fetus
and you know for eight months uh and
then just going ah i don't know that's
not happening there's a there's already
restrictions that they have there's
already restrictions that say at that
moment you like you know guys you know
about gosnell right
women were getting elective abortions at
nine months we're we're talking but we
don't we don't need to argue edge cases
let me go back to michael so we don't
even i want to make a point here because
health of the mother no no no no hold on
hold on i'm sorry man i'm sorry man i
don't want to deviate from the point
because we're i have a sincere question
based on the law
an abortion is is legally defined as
terminating a pregnancy of or relating
to
the end of the ending the baby's life
the baby dies in the process right
if they if if this if if you're saying
okay well abortions also happen when you
know the baby has already died there's
been a miscarriage of course yeah right
so so let me this i read you the law
it would legalize a woman
for for uh the reasons of of health and
good faith
to terminate the baby
up to nine months because of its
viability viabilities extends from 21
weeks until the point of birth
so this bill would allow it would
actually legalize in many states a baby
uh
just before birth
being killed
like aborted right
for medical reasons if there's
no reason well if a mother's life is in
danger or if there's something wrong
with something something something's
wrong with the the fetus well i'm not so
talking about the life of the patient's
life and we're not talking about the
fetus something wrong with the fetus i i
get it like the baby's already dead the
baby's already dead right here's my
question no one's carrying a baby for
eight months and then has to go that's
not an argument if the doctor
is saying no one does a thing is not
real because some people did and some
people don't and we're not talking about
we're talking about the law the law says
if a woman is pregnant and for any
reason do you believe that for any
reason a woman has a right to terminate
her pregnancy me personally yes i
believe it's a woman's body
what's that
so you think a woman who's pregnant with
a baby at nine months she can say
snip its neck i mean
we have laws that basically say they
can't just up snip and snack i mean
that's a really weird way to put it do
you think so do you know how they
perform abortions on late term yes where
they send the the forceps in and cut the
spinal column
you think that's okay for a baby who's
eight and eight eight eight months and
two weeks in a woman's way but they're
not do no one is just effectively doing
that you just said you're not gonna talk
about edge cases then you're going
around talking about edge cases you're
you used i mean when you said no one
does does that i'm going to give you an
example of it happening i'm not trying
to argue that you are so the issue is
i'm not talking about i'm not talking
should it be legal you said yes right
here's my question let me let me ask you
the question and please if the woman is
told by a doctor if you continue with
the pregnancy you will die
right should they kill the baby
at eight months yes if they if the
mother is told that she will die and
there's no way at eight months we're
talking eight months this woman wants
the br the spring wants the baby
they'll they'll do whatever they can to
save the baby that's not the law says
the law allows for the termination of
the baby it says the good faith it says
the doctors uh you know and the doctor
i'm not arguing the woman's not sick if
a woman is sick at eight months the baby
is viable it says after fetal viability
and the doctor says if you continue with
the pregnancy your health is at risk
do you believe it should be legal at
that point to kill the baby but that's
not happening you're talking about this
i'm not asking i'm saying yes or no do
you think it should be legal they're
trying to legalize it doesn't matter if
it's happening they're trying to
legalize it yes or no they're trying to
legalize the fact that women at eight
months pregnant could find out something
is horribly wrong with the fetus where
it will die as soon as it's born be in
pain have cancer the question or not i'm
answering the question to you no no
because you're saying something i agree
with you on and no one disagrees with
you on
everyone wants to preserve the health of
the mother sure why kill the baby in the
process they're not killing the baby in
the process why legalize the killing of
the baby they're not legalized yes they
are read the law i read it to you how
many times after fetal viability the
baby can survive on its own they can
perform an abortion if the mother's
health is at risk why kill the baby why
not include in that all efforts must be
made to save the baby's life it's right
there when it says the
the exact wording i don't have in front
of me because i have my the dot with the
doctor said the good faith efforts of
the doctor the doctor is looking out for
both the patient not the baby abortion
is the termination of the baby if it
wasn't about legalizing the killing of
the baby they would say perform a
c-section or induce labor when they're
with what this is right here it says
they cannot prohibit abortion late-term
abortion is a practice with legal
definitions where the baby is killed its
limbs are removed and it's sucked out
if the mother if the baby is viable why
not just induce labor or perform a
c-section in fact when hassan quoted my
tweet that's what his followers said
apparently they disagree with you i mean
if they can do that they would do that
at eight months for sure and why
legalize
why i just explained to you because it
needs to happen sometimes
for the health of the mother or for the
the child killing the baby yes it needs
to happen if there's something terribly
horribly wrong with a child would you
agree that and immediately die or be in
horrible pain for hours before dying
anyway would you agree with a provision
added to this bill saying all efforts
must be made to preserve the life of any
baby after viability i mean you're
asking for exactly what's there but if
that makes you happy then i mean sure
why not that's but that's not what's
there well so
so we agree we completely agree 100
i mean except for you saying a woman
should decide on later abortion i don't
agree with that okay but so so we agree
this bill should have an extended
provision to protect the life i mean i
think it's there i think it's there
that's my opinion i think it says it
right there which which part do you
think says i must preserve the life
we've already went over this 100 times
it says right in the you think the
doctor is not looking out for both the
mother and the child they are i think
oftentimes the doctors looking out
they're not they're not really looking
out for either i think in many cases
they're trying to make money so that's
harsh
i have numbers for you i have numbers
for you partial birth abortionist john
mcmahon says the primary reason given
for those requesting a late term
abortion is depression uh the guttmacher
institute which is a pro-choice think
tank said that they surveyed women
obtaining late-term abortions they found
that only about one percent of second
and third trimester abortions are
performed for fetal anomalies
which is another way of saying like
eugenics there's a disability so we kill
them
one third of the women said that they
misjudged how far along they were
fourth said they found it hard to
arrange an earlier abortion 14 that they
were afraid to tell their parents or
their partner and the rest gave reasons
such as taking their time to decide or
waiting for a change in their
relationships i will also add the cdc
divines abortion as a termination of a
pregnancy that does not result in live
birth
so my question is why do the democrats
try to legalize the killing of a viable
baby without any protections
i mean i
don't know i mean i'm telling you right
there it says right there exactly but
you're in favor of late term abortion i
think it's up to a mother uh a woman and
her doctor
so i actually agree with uh the initial
roe v wade uh
i i guess i mean have you read roe v
wade of course yeah so you know about
the limitations on the trimester yeah so
so you know about the limitations of
course yes but so do you agree with that
what do you mean that's the law of the
land for now
so so you actually you just told me that
you think a woman should be able to
choose to terminate the baby no i did i
said
the decision of what happens to a
pregnant woman is up to her and her
doctor that's all i'm telling you let me
ask you a question if there was a baby
on a table and someone grabbed a pair of
you know
bolt cutters and put it to its neck
would you stop them
you're talking about a live person right
i'm talking about a baby right just born
right on the spot right that's that's a
person what if the baby was coming out
of the woman and then they snipped it
snapped
but no one's doing that because gus nell
did it don't don't say don't give me an
absolute and then tell me not to make an
edge point don't say no one did it when
someone did it the point is i'm asking
you moral questions on where your
position is so i can understand why you
would support these positions because i
don't understand
so if the baby was delivered you're
saying it can't be killed
now do you understand my tweet
if the woman was intending to abort the
baby at eight months
and went into an early labor while she
was going to the abortion clinic and the
baby was born right there in the lobby
could she not kill it now
well if she had the baby as she was
going to get her eight month abortion
there's something horribly wrong with
that baby i hope it's not in pain
because they were she was going to
answer the question i just i'm going
talking about it i said can
okay oh can she if the baby is born no
because that's a person so what if so
now let's move backwards the baby is a
person the moment it's born right
is that what you're saying yes what if
the baby is halfway out halfway up like
so do you know they do late term
abortions at the point of birth
partial birth abortions the baby is
coming out and they kill it as it comes
out
okay
that's literally what they do
bro
i believe women have the right to choose
within the first trimester and partly
into the second trimester
because the government can't mandate
someone else give their body to someone
else the challenge i have
as a traditional liberal and social
liberal is when you start introducing
the rights of secondary persons to the
equation like roe v wade actually stated
the privacy rights of the baby enter at
the point of viability these questions
are difficult to answer so my position
has always been safe legal rare first
trimester discretion of the woman even
though i really don't like the idea of
abortion as contraception so you like
you like where it is right now
that's a hard thing to say considering
all the states have different no i think
it's a very easy thing to say because
you said it's safe legal and rare right
which states
i don't like where it's not because
colorado legalized nine-month partial
birth abortion kathy tran in virginia
tried doing the same i don't know where
they went on that and ralph northam
actually said the baby would be
delivered and then they would decide
they have a discussion that's not what
he said he was talking he said they
would have discussed he was talking
about if there's context right before
where he said that if there was
something horribly wrong with the baby
like the baby's born in a vegetative
state and he's not going to live a life
that you know it's not i don't say that
i didn't say that he didn't say that he
said but you didn't you didn't say that
he did either
so for one we've played the video
multiple times what he said was this
typically so he's asked by the presenter
kathy tran presented a bill that would
legalize abortion up to the point of
birth he said typically this happens in
instances of severe disability or
deformity and i will tell you what would
happen the baby would be delivered it
would be resuscitated if that's what
they decided it would be made
comfortable
and then a discussion would happen
so my my issue there is i i disagree i
mean if it's if a baby is alive
i think every effort must be made to try
and save its life i think if a homeless
person is bleeding and they fall onto
the stairs of a hospital the hospital
absolutely must save that person's life
the same thing as a baby that's born
with deformities or otherwise i don't
think you can see a person and be like
they're dying we should kill them
whether it's a baby or otherwise so the
issue here is
i'm pro-choice what was your what was
your feelings on the terry chavo case
oh
i don't have strong opinions on that one
i mean for one
you don't you don't you don't you just
don't care well i just say i don't care
all right it's a difficult moral
question i know the answers to okay so
first who did you think who did you more
to lean towards there i'd probably say
we would lean towards preserving the
life of terry chavo even though that's
not what she wanted
well if that was the case i don't know
enough about it if she signed uh do not
resist it no she literally she told her
husband that she did not want to be left
in a vegetative state then that's her
right with the saying a dnr absolutely
this was according to her husband and
there was no formal paperwork and her
parents said we will take care of it and
you can't do it yeah if she had a dnr i
respect the dnr it's her life it's her
choice uh without illegal without
illegal do not resuscitate then you have
to defer the next of kin as for
the the husband would be that
well right i mean i'm not the boss of
people i'm not the i'm not the king no
no no no no no no no because we just we
just we the the the the thing that james
just said and then you agreed with was
that um if she is in a vegetative state
and the husband says
that i was told by her that that's it
and then he brought up how there's no
proof of that the parents wanted her
alive they said they would take care of
her
they're not the next kind though the
husband is the husband has the ultimate
decision of her
of her care right yes i agree that's not
i'm well i'm adding the context because
he said if she signed paperwork and so
i'm i'm pointing out that that was not
the situation okay yeah all right just
making sure just being present clear
here so social liberals is a reference
to it so wait so do you so do you think
that you know in the case of a child's
health that you know and they are not
adults so they can't make decisions
themselves do you think the parent can
make that decision for a child's health
yes absolutely okay so if a baby is born
in a vegetative state
can the parent decide to put it out of
its misery and not let it just die a
slow agonizing death and say i am the
next of kin
this is not how this life should be
we should just end that life and life
support no
you don't think that's no the baby
wasn't involved in a traumatic injury
right so there's there's there's
questions they were they were they were
they were born with a a life-altering
could not even probably won't perhaps
won't live yeah and you're saying it's
okay for them to be in a vegetative
state for who knows how long uh they
likely will die in a few months maybe
maybe even make it a year just in in the
hospital yeah you're saying that
anything you want to it i i think
there's a difference between someone who
suffered so you don't think you don't
think parents have you don't think
parents have the right to do what's best
for their children well that's this
thing she said that can i you just said
that no let's just start baby isn't the
best for the baby yes that is it's a
parent's decision if the baby is in a
vegetative state and will never have any
quality of life the humane caring loving
thing for a parent
edge cases what are you talking about
exactly now who's arguing no because you
brought up the ralph i know my answer
the answer is you brought up the ralph
northam thing i gave you the answer so
you don't think that clearly don't agree
with the idea that a baby is born with
deformity you kill it i clearly told me
just
talking about
we're not talking about with like a limp
arm or something we're talking about a
quality of life disability where they
will never be able to have any quality
can i can say the same thing over and
over again i believe that we should not
allow doctors to kill a baby regardless
uh i think every effort should be made
to preserve the life of the baby okay so
you don't think that people should have
a right to die with dignity at all
basically
kathy newman we're not talking about
that
if a woman i think that's i think it all
i think it all really if it wasn't like
terry suffers a stroke a disease
she's older and later in life and she
has the ability to make a cognitive
decision or her next of kin does and
it's the issue of do we pull her off
life support that's different from a
newborn baby in a different way but no
the legal context is the parents have
the full right to do what's best for
their child
this is a conservative position too by
the way in terms of parents having
something i got to tell you i'm a
liberal okay
so let me make a point okay
the the the the issue uh well go ahead
go ahead well because we have to
distinguish between two things there are
situations where a person is
injured to the point where they require
extraordinary measures in in in order to
stay alive so we're not talking about
you know food water basic treatment
we're talking about things like being
hooked up to an insane amount of
machines uh things that are incredibly
burdensome there is a difference between
a person in that situation who's saying
without all of these unnatural means i
would die so pull the plug and saying
this person's alive but they're
suffering so we're going to kill them
there's a difference between pulling the
plug in a life support situation where
that person requires extraordinary means
to stay alive and a person who is alive
and is sustained but you're deciding to
go out of your way to kill them those
are two different situations yeah that's
a good point but he's but also i think
the point you're making too is if the
baby was in a situation where it was
dying let's say the baby's born with a
hole in its heart which happens and it's
bleeding too fast for them to to try and
surgically repair my answer is repair it
let's say a baby's born without a brain
it's happened before yeah uh
i i do not i think the issue is i'll
tell you why i i take the pro-choice
stance the traditional liberal one not
the modern liberal one
i don't believe the government has a
right to dictate a person give their
body or blood to another person and
there are questions of
privacy and there are questions of
government overreach however when it's
when another person enters the equation
you have one person sharing two bodies
that's why i'm like
you know so so second third trimester
abortions are where things get get risky
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you